okay let me follow up about Tucker
Carlson yesterday Tucker Carlson we
talked about unearthed I don't want to
use the term leak but unearth audio from
Tucker Carlson's appearance on the Bubba
the Love Sponge Show years ago where he
said that women are experiment extremely
primitive they need to be quiet and do
what they're told he refused to condemn
cult leader Warren Jeffs or sort of
downplayed his horrible activity and now
Tucker Carlson is refusing to apologize
and I actually think this is the right
decision I'm not saying morally it's the
right decision but it is the right
decision if your Tucker Carlson and I'll
explain it momentarily just as a
reminder here's one clip of Tucker
saying women should be quiet and do what
they're told you know in my brief
experience you know gets women going is
arguing with them really yeah honey
non-brand I never use it sure you debate
politics with a woman and just go you
know just full blown out there
especially feminism if you're talking to
a feminist and she's giving you well you
know men really need to be more
sensitive and this you know actually men
don't need to be more sensitive you just
need to be quiet and kind of do what
you're told and lighten up a little bit
they love it and then the part about
women being primitive again we played
this yesterday just getting everybody up
to speed
hey let's go crazy how old is your
daughter 14 I love women but they're
extremely primitive their basic they're
not that hard to understand okay so he
was smeared and attacked by all sorts of
people and rightly so I mean these
comments are disgusting and they're not
surprising in that most people who
understood Tucker Carlson realized that
this is what he was thinking all along
even if he wasn't saying it nightly on
his Fox News program but I think he's
making the right move by not apologizing
number one who would he be apologizing
to his Fox News audience mostly agrees
with him about this stuff they like this
stuff that's why Tucker Carlson is
popular there's a much longer list of
these types of assertions by Tucker
Carlson he previously said 30
year old boys having sex with adult
women is fine he called an end to for an
end to rape shield laws so that victims
would no longer be able to hide behind
anonymity he called specific women pigs
and [ __ ] including Britney Spears and
Paris Hilton and Arianna Huffington
he said Supreme Court justice Elena
Kagan is ugly Trump did the same stuff
and was elected president of the United
States so why would Tucker Carlson
apologize particularly when the apology
opens himself up to the framing that he
acknowledges he did something wrong so
within the tucker carlson fox news
universe pat not apologizing strengthens
his strong man alpha male credentials
bowtie notwithstanding and I don't see
any upside to apologizing for something
that only people who already don't watch
Tucker Carlson would even be upset with
yeah because I don't think people in his
audience are even offended by those
comments and also an apology would just
make him look weak he doesn't want to
look like a pushover I think that I'm
going to employ this tactic for future
Pat scandals like there's no sense than
me apologizing for them anymore and I'm
going to do that now yeah the audience
loves you for them so why apologize and
like I said yesterday am i calling for
Tucker Carlson to be fired no that's
silly his audience and apparently Fox
News agrees with most of this am i
calling for an advertiser boycott no
last time he said something hugely
disgusting some advertisers bailed but
enough stayed that the program still
makes financial sense for Fox News why
would the advertisers bail a lot of them
have been with him for a while if they
choose to we don't need to lobby them to
do that
if these comments are actually
off-putting to Tucker sorrel audience
his audience will stop watching
advertisers will say hey we don't
advertise on shows that nobody watches
because it's a waste of money and Fox
News is going to say we don't employ
hosts for shows that nobody watches I
don't think that's going to happen I
suspect his audience it's fine with
these comments meaning the show will be
profitable for Fox News and the show
will still be profitable for advertisers
and that's
so I think everything he said is
deplorable I think it's disgusting
but he is right from a strategic
perspective not to apologize and in fact
if you saw the segment he did last night
touting why he's not going to be pushed
by the mob or something like that he
used the word mob into apologizing
he's probably winning as a result of
this entire fiasco if you disagree with
me let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show I am thrilled to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman Blink
astiz a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's B
Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n